مجرد ما كان ابني يدور على نتفن تقاوى
فيها الله اكرمه بهالناس المحترمين قال
لهم معاي ست كبيره مريضه وابويا عامل
عمليه وبدي اتاو انا واياهم واختي صم
واخوي صم وبدي اتاو انا واياهم فاستقبلوه
بصدر الرحم الحمد لله والله لا بنعرفهم
ولا عرفونا ولا عمرهم شافونا ولا شفناهم
بدات المعاناه مثل مثلنا مثل بقيه الشعب
الفلسطيني بوصول نازحين من شمال قطاع غزه
وجدنا هؤلاء الناس مالهم ماوى يعني في
الشوارع فجبنا بعض العائلات على قدر
استطاعتنا وكان عننا مخازن هنا عباره عن
محلات يعني معجره لناس والناس طبعا مع
الحرب سكرت هي المخازن فطلعنا بضاعتهم
وحطيناها في مكان امن وسكنا فيها
تقدر تقول 17 اسره يعني تقريبا يعني قول
معدل اسره يعني 10 170 فرد
عننا جايه
الميه عبد الله جايه وجهنا مشكله الميه
اخذنا خط من جنبنا من جمعيه خط طاقه شمسيه
بعد فتره تضررت الطاقه اضطرينا نجيب مولد
كهرب وجبنا غاز رغم شخ الغاز على حسابنا
مدينا خطوط للجيران ولل الحاره ونازحين
لعنا واجوا نازحين بعد فتره في خيام
تقريبا تقريبا 270 خيمه بتخلص الميه فنضطر
نعبي التنكات المغرب عشان نظل للصبح الناس
بتيجي تعبي
[موسيقى]
مي
البير اللي عننا كان مصمم للبيت بضخ كل
يوم اربعه الى 5000 لتر الان بضخ فوق ال
50 600 الف لتر في
اليوم اصحاب الخبره اللي بعرفوا الابار
قالوا لنا في مخاطره على الغاطس عندكم
ممكن ينحرق الحمد لله يعني بمشيه الرحمن
ظل سالك ضل شغال قال ليش عشانك مصاحب
ماه وفروا لنا السكن تقاسمنا معهم السكن
تقاسمنا معهم الاكل وال المشرب وفروا لنا
المياه وفروا لنا كل سبل
الحياه والله انا بعدهم اولادي يشهد الله
في كل المعامله اللي استقبلونا فيها فتح
حضورهم اننا والله العظيم وعفشه واثاث وكل
شي من عندهم والميه والكرم والجود صاروا
اخوان واعمام واهل وهذه زي امي وهذه زي
اختي وهذه زي خالتي اسره وحده حتى احنا
صرنا نفكر كيف لو بدهم يروحوا الناس هذه
كيف يعني صار جزء من العائله بصراحه وهم
كلهم يعني عائلات كريمه ولا يستحق ل
جرالهم بامانه لكن الشي مش بيدنا هذا هذا
الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
يعني